James is it my right is this year your  third movie yeah what hurt yeah yeah  what's going on uh you know she's really  difficult to work with and I think I'm  probably the only guy in the initiative  is willing to do it yeah the rumor she's  honestly she's seriously brilliant and I  love working with her but to be honest  we work to each other the last like what  the last five years were three times  together we've got like two scenes with  each other at each film that we've done  so please if there's anybody out there  that wants to hire doesn't actually give  us lots of work together um amen  yeah me too so it just it just works and  it just feels like there's gonna be a  neck thing for the rest of your lives  you're just gonna keep doing movies with  each other yeah what other couple does  that what other like acting couple does  that can you think Oh Laurel and Hardy  yeah that'd be go there we go we are the  next rain and they were married in real  life yeah having Castella